[Music]
okay I've got to talk to you I'm going
to gush about this one I got to talk to
you about the fact that you are going to
be voicing the spider-man upcoming
animated project is that confirmed or
not is that another thing
you see the thing is I was told I can't
but it can't parently I can't okay
talk about this animated project I'm
excited about your voicing Miles Morales
yes how geeked were you when you found
out you were gonna be doing this I
waited a very long time to hear back
from them I thought I didn't get it
you know honestly but when I got that
call like yeah you know I'm more than
excited or thankful I am voicing Miles
Morales the black spider-man I am a
black young man it's very very very very
powerful to me it says a lot in my
journal before dope
I drew I am spider-man and then on the
next page I drew I am Miles Morales
across the whole like two pages of it in
like two years later you know he's yeah
Wow a way to like stick words of
affirmation I mean that's inspiration
for everybody that has a dream like that
and write it down yeah write it down in
a dress I need to get a journal pencil
until in pain so a pen and paper put
your dream slip in a paper
[Music]
you